- Every morning I wake
up and I make pretend
that my mother, or children, or wife die.
(gentle music)
The only consistent in my life
has been perspective and gratitude,
it's the only consistent in my life.
Every morning I wake up and make pretend
that my mother, or children, or wife die.
I promise you, if you're
in touch with your feelings
and you can trick yourself to feel it,
even right now I felt it a little bit
and it really fuckin' hurts,
like, nothing else matters.
I'm completely driven by gratitude.
I keep things in very simple perspective.
I'm thrilled and very in tune with my ego.
I'm also very thrilled and
in tune with my humility.
I think I'm the best
and I think that if I disappear tomorrow
nobody really gives a shit.
And so, that yin and yang
is very important to me,
and so what I do consistently,
and have for 30 years now, is
I keep things in perspective.
I want legacy.
I think the reason I'm liked is 'cause
I'll reply to somebody, who says
they're on their way here to see me talk,
on twitter and reply to her.
I'm playing a different game, I ...
Tyler is filming today's Daily Vee,
I met with a former employee
and he flat out broke the wall
and he was like, "Dude,
I just have to ask you,
"why did you take that meeting?
"It's a former employee,
one that you fired,
"one that came to tell
you that they were sorry
"for not getting it,
she pitched you stuff.
"You didn't get anything out of it."
He said, "Why'd you do that?"
And I said, "Because making money
"isn't the only thing that interests me."
I love the process more than
the riches and the fames.
When people ask me, "When
are you gonna buy the Jets?"
and I always say 25 years from now,
they're disappointed, I'm pumped.
(laughing)
It's amazing to me.
They're literally disappointed.
I'm like, "It's $3 billon,
I have work to do."
(laughing)
I'm not crippled by the current
political correctness of parenting.
You're looking at a kid
who didn't see his dad
until he was 14 years old and we have
the greatest relationship
of all-time and I love him.
And he slept home every single night
but I never saw him once.
That doesn't mean my workaholic nature
will work for me and my kids,
I don't take that for granted.
I think that you need
to know how to breathe.
I know what makes me breathe.
My family makes me breathe,
but I've gotta do what I wanna do.
Like, I have to.
I'll just break.
Everybody in here has
different work/life balance.
You also have different work/life balance
at different times in your life.
I don't think you find balance
in any other way than your own balance,
and I think that over-communication
with your partner
and the variables in that
relationship are the key.
I'm working harder, right this second,
than I ever have in my entire life.
That's why I started Daily Vee,
just wanted to put all of you on notice
like, you're not working as hard as I am.
And, I wanted to do that
because people think they're
putting in enough work,
they're just not.
Everybody's talking shit,
everybody loves to hit me up,
Gary Vee hustling.
I look at their account
and they're playing ping pong at 4:30.
(laughing)
I mean, people don't
understand what hustle is.
I took one vacation in my 20s,
but I have crazy aspiration.
You should take 11, but
don't come telling me
you're gonna by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
So, people get my message confused.
They're like, "You're
always talking about hustle,
where's life?"
I'm like, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no!"
If you're a hundred
percent happy, like I am,
then I got no advice for
you, you figured it out.
So, when my rich friends complain to me
about not spending enough
time with their family,
they're real easy to give advice to, too,
spend more time with your family.
This shit is binary,
this stuff is so basic,
we complicate it.
And, I'm happy when people have ambitions
that allow them to work 40 hours a week
and they're thrilled, I have to move fast.
Like everybody tells me Vander
was not gonna be successful
if I move too fast.
They were wrong, 'cause I'm fast.
Let's play out the scenario.
I grew too fast, I
couldn't afford my staff,
I had to cut people
then people got scared we weren't stable,
they quit and my shit got fucked up.
That's scary of going too fast.
Let me tell you what
happens way more often.
90% of this room is going too slow
and has left tons of money on the table
but they don't know it 'cause it's hidden.
It's not obvious to anybody
if you're doing a million
but you should be doing three million
but you're going too slow.
I mean, I love when everybody's like,
"Well, it's easy for you."
It wasn't always.
Like, you weren't with
me when I was in my house
printing on that slow-ass computer.
Ya know, 20% off a case of wine
and then I grab the whole thing
and then I, fuckin', woke up at 6 a.m.
And went to the Short Hills Mall
and just went and put that on the flyer.
You weren't with me.
People think things are below them.
I still don't think things are below me.
Like, nothing is below
me, I'll do anything.
And so, the first thing
is figure out who you
are and what you want,
and then deploy real self-awareness.
But, I'm telling you, the
thing that I'm fearful of
and the reason I didn't
step off stage yet is,
it's been so good for almost
a decade, this has been easy.
There's so much money out there,
everybody's getting money
for their dumb ideas
that make no money.
People are getting funded for everything,
so if you haven't been able
to figure out how to get money
you're a triple loser.
So the way to answer that,
and punch me in the face
and tell me that you're
not, is go make money
instead of dwelling why
you haven't raised it.
I promise you something about money,
money's real funny, real funny,
money doesn't care what you look like.
Here's most people's strategies in life.
(laughing)
if you are not capable,
in 2017, to Google shit
and figure out what's going
on in the world, fuck you.
We have to start getting into meritocracy.
Somebody should lose if they're not seeing
where the puck is going.
If you drivin' a truck,
today, you know it's coming.
You've heard it, somebody told you.
So, either, you take it seriously
and you start educating
yourself or you don't.
That's the game.
That's life and that's the historic nature
of human beings forever.
So, just 'cause we're, now, living
and it's our turn to go through something,
this has always happened.
I don't see truck driver Johnny
feeling bad for Rick the bookstore owner
'cause Amazon came along.
This is the first time that
innovation fucked shit up.
Nobody's cryin' for the
farmers in middle America.
people, in Cleveland,
who own the docks.
And so, what 55 year
old Charles has to do,
when he is out of a
job, is get another job
whatever that job is.
So if Charles is smart and has skills
he's teaching himself something now
to be ready for three years from now.
But, Charles wants to watch football.
Here's the punchline,
the market is the market.
What is the 54 year old gonna do, adjust
or lose?
(gentle music)